Somebody should blow you the away until your type of people do
not exist in the society that I live in anymore. And I'm fully
here for it 100%. Whether that includes burning down buildings,
attacking people.
Okay, so we're going to go. Let's refresh on the context on this.
It's like Destiny basically saying, okay, what did he say here?
I think Hassan reads it. If Dan wants to do something useful
and still be a Hassan hater, he should create a track Hassan
X account that posts Hassan Hassan's current location where he's
when he's out at protests. His location should be publicly available
at all times. He's live streaming while he's live. >> Now,
obviously after the like the Charlie Kirk thing for one, the
attacks on the female streamers, so the attacks on Emiru at TwitchCon,
the attacks on was it SA Emiru?
Uh, who else was there? Valkyrie,
right? You remember this one? Like IRL live streamers need delays
just to avoid getting attacked. The idea that you're like talking
about this is a little weird.
Right off the bat, right at a base level. Okay.
Already strange.
Really was saying that Destiny statement wasn't that bad. I have
that tweet. Yeah. I don't know. I don't So,
as far as I can tell, that's probably just getting caught by
the classic Destiny Men Bailey, right? He says something totally
in an in an emotionally disregulated state that isn't even like
it's maybe like slightly related to the thing, but it's not really
right. It's like it's not the thing that was said. He like comes
up with an excuse after the fact. Oh, actually, I was just making
a point that how like we should demand Trump denounce violence.
No, you weren't. You were saying conservatives should be scared.
You want conservatives scared. That's what you said. Why are
you pretending it was the other thing? It wasn't the other thing.
It literally wasn't.
Why are you just lying? A lot of people fall for this M Bailey.
I don't know why. Um, but I'm guessing that's all it is. I I
I think. We'll see. Let me Let me give it a listen again. >> If
Dan wants to do something useful [laughter] and still be a Hassan
hater, he should create a track Hassan X account that posts his
current location when he's out at protest. His location should
be publicly available at all times while he's live streaming.
This is him at his cult.
I just want to clarify what I was saying here because it sounds
like um
it sounds like I'm saying that his like live location or whatever
should be broadcast or whatever was at protest. That is exactly
what I'm saying and it should be and he should be bullied. People
should scream at him and shout at him and bully him the out of
any left-leaning protest that you see. The CCP paid agitator
should never be in any democratic liberal protest ever. If you
like, bro, just imagine imagine
this happening with like anybody else,
right? You would never forgive this level of dog whistling with
anyone else
I just think I think Hassan's location should be tracked at all
time at all times. You should have his live location anytime
he's outside of his house. Anytime he's at a protest, you should
have his live location so you can go up and shake his hand peacefully.
So you can go up and say, "Hey, Hassan, I really like your stream."
That's why you should track his live location, guys.
Uh, hold on. There's a fantastic tweet here. Hold on.
Chilipi. Chilipi had a tweet for me. Funny. I I got this guy's
tweet in my feed today. It's this one. That's That's this right
here. Okay. Hey, why why do you have that can of soup? >> Well,
I've been here uh all four nights. Uh I'm just standing here
today with uh soup for my family and uh we're just, you know,
>> Wait, why'd you do that little wink? I thought that
is that soup for your >> Soup for my family. And uh we're
just, you know, watching all this unfold. It's very unfortunate.
>> You're not planning on using that, are you? Throwing
it at the police. >> Like I said, it's for my family. >> Well,
I've been >> It's just for his family, guys. Why would
he want to track your live location? It's just for It's just
to keep you safe. Okay. They want to keep you safe. That's why
your location should be broadcast live for the entire internet
at all times because we just want to keep you safe, man.
Right. It's like the same thing. It's like, okay, you can you
can pretend we're all, but we're not. We can all see what you're
doing. Obviously, dude, it's just goofy to pretend otherwise.
It's It's very goofy.
>> He wants to go hang out with disgusting, smelly, fat.
>> Now he's going to try to tie it to like the CCP or some
other reason because he knows he said something insane again.
He knows he's doubling on down on something totally.
So, he needs to make up some pretext for why this is okay. Well,
Hassan actually takes money from China. That's why it's okay
for me to say this because Hassan takes money. And then a bunch
of people go, "Wait, I really do hate Assan and I do think he
takes money from China. I do think he does Chinese propaganda."
That makes the first part okay. No, it doesn't.
Tim Pool provably took money from Russia. We're not going to
advocate for Tim P's death.
Outside of a courtroom, um, we're not going to advocate for anything
like that. Okay?
We haven't watched the Henry Brazilian video yet. No losers,
the tanky or whatever. He can go hang out with those losers.
That's absolutely fine. But until he has made a public statement
that fully accounts for how he was compensated by the Chinese
Communist Party for his little hate vacation.
Um, yes, Ashley Klein, this is what gives us insight into what
he's really thinking, right?
When he said a girl posting his location on X, I think, was doxing
him and trying to get him killed.
Why can't you just take that his thoughts on I'm a public figure.
I'm a controversial public figure posting my public location
saying you want somebody to go and egg me, right? Destiny saying
go bully him. It's like already solved the whole equation. It's
a closed system. We already know exactly what he means. We already
know exactly what he's
I don't even know how you could get fooled by this. You'd have
to be a complete [__]
trip with him and the rest of his little streamer to China until
he has publicly announced and addressed that and talked about
it. I have no idea why the you would want this guy anywhere near
any of your liberal protests. Absolutely it out. One of the hugest
issues that this country has right now is all of the foreign
interference that is just happening openly on all of our social
media platforms by the same countries that paid this loser to
go and do a sh who couldn't even go through with it. He couldn't
even let the guy
his neck, okay, at the stupid um chiropractic place cuz he knew
how the stuff that he was promoting was. But he was getting paid
too much, compensated too much by the Chinese government to say
no, okay, so this guy letting him anywhere near your product.
Let's go hang out with Republicans. Go to the dangerous places
and get shot. Okay, all of us will clap for you. I promise. All
right. Go to the Republican places. Go to the edgy places. Go
hang out with tankies or whatever. But stay though.
>> Go get shot. We'll all clap. >> Was But he was
getting paid too much. Compensated too much by the Chinese government
to >> Hold on. What did Dan say? Dan said something in
the >> But he was getting paid too much. Compensated too
much by the Chinese government to say no. Okay. So this guy letting
him anywhere near go hang out with Republicans. Go to the dangerous
places and get shot. Okay. All of us will clap for you. I promise.
All right. Go to the Republican places. Go to the edgy places.
Go hang out with tankies or whatever. But stay the away from
liberal protest. This fat losser.
I I
balding graying piece of to show up at a liberal protest for
6 hours. You can come and finger wave. And >> yeah, this
was this was a weirdly weird clip. We watched it the other day.
He's just like >> virtually signal to everybody else that
you do that you matter. You don't matter. Nobody likes you. Top
10 crash outs all time right here. Just saying things that make
no sense over >> maintaining the now majority position.
>> That's what I got to say about that.
>> Is apparently fat, gray, balding, all of these things.
Has no friends. Surely that's not us just projecting. Surely
that's like a real thing that is true and not just projecting.
>> He's telling him like don't just stalk him the way that
you've been stalking
Stalk him better.
Stalk him directly.
what a crybaby victim.
Hassan, the problem is that
dude, there's no way he had all of those debates about the egg
girl, argued with everybody that she was trying to get him killed,
and then he goes, "Oh, Hassan, when I suggest that like we should
track his live location and go up to him at protest." Uh, no,
no, no. What a cry. What a crybaby [__]
You out of your
bro? What? Hassaned up because he he he couldn't. Okay. Who's
got Oh, wait. Hold on. We got this the other day. Oh, who was
it? It was Weaszly Little Liar, right? Is Weasley Little Liar
here? Uh, Weasley.
Is this guy not here? [snorts]
Weas some guy named Weasley
right here. He said this was it. I think this time I was you
deleted the tweets about the college girl after she apologized.
Thought you said you don't care for apologies. Uh, no. But at
least she she realized what she did was drawing, so I'll delete
it.
You saw the Britney comments. Destiny sweats the night. >> Uh,
no. I don't even know. >> This is after he doxed a girl.
He He counterdoced a girl who gave his location away. Said, "Oh,
Destiny was speaking on a campus or something." She She tweeted
something like, "Destiny's over here. I'll give somebody money
if they go like egg him or something." Right. Um,
oh, real quick thing. Okay,
real quick thing. Uh, I don't know how to get this across. Okay.
Um, who just joined? Are you about to say some?
>> No, I was gonna ask you, did you want
Oh, wow. So cool.
What a what a throwback. That's esports Batman just joined. What
a throwback, guys.
Any >> background on the targeted US killings that Paul
was talking about? Or are you just concerned about the uh >> targeted
US killings? Oh, no. That's I'll go over. >> So, sorry,
esports. You need to go >> Here's the thing. Okay, firstly,
people are arguing over whether or not I doxed that girl. Okay,
I did. I did dox that person. Just the classic, um, you're saying
I did something bad. I did. I do double down on that. You're
saying I did a bad thing. I do did that. I did do that. I do
did that. Okay. And here's why I had to do that because it's
really important to not let people dox you and to like if they
publish my live location, they're trying to get me.
So this was two years ago, April 2023, almost three years ago.
>> Collecting information, even if public, for the purposes
of harassing somebody is doxing. And that is what I did. I did
do it. And I would do it again. If you are going to post p and
that is what I did. I did do it. And I would do it again. If
you are going to post pictures of where I'm at and even jokingly
suggest or offer to pay people to come and attack me, I will
do whatever the I can. Okay. To with your life. Absolutely. Ab.
So like the only thing he'd have to stand on here now obviously
is the word bullying versus throw an egg at
broh. And anybody that thinks even well isn't it blah blah blah
off yourselves and don't unfollow me and leave cuz I will do
this over and over and over again. I will keep doing it. If you're
deranged enough to on an account where your information is so
easily locatable to take a picture of me, post it somewhere.
Destiny is here at this time and I'll pay you money if you go
and attack him. [__] you. Yeah, of course I'm going
to bring down the weight of the world on you. You're
attacking was throw an egg by the way. Okay.
Now, is throw an egg tangibly different from
Uh,
I
Yeah, technically it's assault. Technically, you could go yell
epithets to somebody and that's not assault and you could egg
somebody and it's assault. But realistically, in terms of, hey,
I'm going to publish it. Was that really what he's concerned
about? Let's be honest. Was he concerned about the idea that
it was the egging or was he concerned about the idea that somebody
was with negative intention wanting his live location published?
Which one was he actually concerned about? Right. Crazy
to think that that's even remotely acceptable. You're absolutely
out of your mind. And I will do it more and more and more in
the future if I ever see somebody do it again. I did go through
the account. I made sure it was out before I tweeted. Oh, somebody
already said, somebody says right here, Destiny, you were already
live streaming it. What is the issue with the pictures and then
I went hard and I will do it. You're the fact that somebody would
even think that's acceptable.
>> yeah, we just pointed this out. Yeah, Klein. Yeah, we
just pointed this out. Yep. 26-year-old
the Mottton Bailey moment says something totally deranged in
a moment of complete emotional dysregulation and then he goes,
"Actually, here's why I did say it." And then he makes some up
that is not based on principles at all. That is just based on,
you know, trying to cover his ass.
It's done. It's been done many times. It'll be done many more
times. >> Person think that that's acceptable. You are
out of
>> uh Did I dox those guys? Yeah, I did dox those guys
because they're like Kiwi farmers. That's why I dox those guys.
Okay. Yes, I will dox anybody like that. You're [__]
mine. Okay. I do not care. Runday was saying, "Well, he advertised
where he was." I don't care. First of all, I don't think I did
for this event. First of all, I do not believe that I did. I
think we didn't purposefully advertise this one because we didn't
want fans to show up. Um, number one. Number two, even if I did,
even if I did advertise it, I don't I don't know how to make
you guys understand this. I like if you really disagree with
this, post an email and I'll pay people to follow you and do
this. I don't know how you need to you have some empathy for
me. For me to be for me to check my phone and see that somebody
has posted a picture of where I'm at right now saying, "Hey,
somebody go egg this dude or somebody go attack this guy like
I'll pay money for it." You're out of your mind to think that
I would see something like that. And then >> I just love
that he says egg and then he's like wait no I have to say attack
so people consider me more of the >> you're real life information
attached to it and not bring the weight of the world down. You're
out of your mind for that. That is insane to me. You're way the
[__] over the line at that point. It's not even close.
This is like it's one of those things where like sometimes somebody
say yo um this guy uh he punched a dude in the face and it looked
like he was reaching for a knife and the other guy took out a
gun and shot him and I'm like I'd have to think about that one.
I don't know if that's right or not. Right. This is one where
somebody's like, "A guy posted a picture of this dude and said,
"I'll pay money for somebody to go egg this guy." And then the
guy docks. I'm like, "Oh, that's fine. I don't even NEED YOU
TO FINISH THE SENTENCE." YEAH, that's it's the easiest thing
in the world. I can't even believe there's a debate. I can't
even believe there's a debate over it. The the I I I I don't
even I don't even really It's so obliv It's so obvious. It feels
stupid to even bring it up.
One is you're soliciting violence. Whether you think it's a big
deal or not, and it's not, by the way, somebody just throwing
an egg is not the most violent thing. But the problem is you're
pushing somebody to that point at all. So, I don't know if somebody's
going to show up and start doing something. I don't know if that
situation will escalate. Um, meaning somebody throws something
at me and then one of my fans attack them and then something
gets crazy. I don't know if that person would come and do something
more. Well, if I could show up and throw an egg at him, maybe
I can throw a rock at him, right? I don't know that. I just fought
with half of Islam on my Twitter three weeks ago or two weeks
ago. Um, I don't know if somebody would show up, throw something,
cause a little bit of a commotion, and then I'm perma banned
from campus, right? which I'm pretty sure has happened on campuses
before where somebody u somebody somebody shows up and even if
they don't start the fight if somebody else starts the fight
you're just perma banned from that campus because they don't
want you there anymore because they're causing problems. There
are so many and then those are like the weak things. The biggest
thing is like somebody says like oh this dude I remember I'm
going to show up and knife this guy. I'm going to show up and
this guy or I'm going to
do something more. I'm going to show up with four friends and
like cause some big problems. Like it's just all of that is so
stupid. How do you feel about the egging/mil shagging is simulated
assassination? Um, I would agree with it, but I think that the
average view
>> I
I just think this is very funny overall. Um, just the the idea
that it could escalate. Oh, that's a really big deal, guys. You
don't know how that could escalate escalate. You post somebody's
like picture, you post their location, you tell, "Hey, go go
get this guy. Go with this guy." And then you don't know how
it'll escalate. Yeah, that's um that's true, man. It seems weird
that you could totally identify this back then. or you included
is too
even remotely empathize with that position. I understand it.
I make a lot of money for what I do or whatever. So, you think
if I get like kidnapped and raped and all that, it's like funny
and hilarious or whatever. But the idea of somebody posting pictures
where you're at and then calling people to go there and do to
you is it's another it's another world to me that anybody could
think that that's okay. Like at that point, you have to take
a step back and dramatically re-evaluate what is going on in
your tiny peanut braid mind to think that that type of tweet
isn't going to be met with the like harshest of like
I It's unbelievable. But yeah, anyway, so if you were disappointed
by my actions there and you thought I overreacted or whatever,
I will do it again repeatedly over and over in the future. If
I ever see anybody do it, I stand by it. I do not disavow it.
Same thing with the Dust Kid. I don't disavow any of that. I
feel the exact same way 100%. Okay? I'm a big self-defense kind
of guy. All right? If you're actually with somebody, if you're
stealing [__] from somebody, you're doing [__]
somebody should blow you the away until your type of people do
not exist in the society that I live in anymore. And I'm fully
here for it 100%. Whether that includes burning down buildings,
attacking people,
>> wow, it's like
it's almost like he's justifying everybody going after him right
now on this.
It's almost like he's he's justifying a lot of stuff at the same
time. Marty Epste, thank you for the 22 months. Appreciate it,
man.
Very interesting. Very interesting how this is flipped now. Stealing
from stores whatever this goes. Apparently three more minutes,
four more minutes on the clip and then we can go back to the
rest of the stuff. >> [__] you. Okay, we've
moved on from that. It's 2023. We don't do that anymore. If you
want to do it, go do it in some up country or get blown the away
for it. Okay, [__] around. Find out. Die. Okay. In
a video game. Huh. Okay. Interesting. So interesting. Thoughts
on the good publicity argument?
Destiny defending Hassan from Destiny's insane threats of IRL
stalking and
Crazy, isn't it?
It's wild.
back to this clip. >> And then we've got some more stuff
from today. Okay. >> Hassan, the problem is that Hassan
up because he he he couldn't accurately call out the administration
when the election time came around cuz he just wanted to talk
about Israel. So Hassan has no moral platform. has truly if Assan
gave a [__] about US politics truly he would just
go back to Turkey or he would off himself um like get himself
off of the uh political scene is what I mean by that. Um he has
no right he's he has no place to speak about American politics
right now given away how he >> Okay. Wow. >> So then
apparently Asminold reacts to this clip. All right. We had we
had an Asold reaction to this clip. Let's check it out. >> Destiny
has accused Tassan of being paid by the CCP.
Um, to the best of my knowledge, he Dan said that's not true.
And through an interesting,
what's the best way to say this? I know more about that than
the public does. And from everything that I know publicly,
I don't think that's
I don't. Stupid um chiropractic place cuz he knew how the stuff
that he was promoting was, but he was getting paid too much.
>> There's a lot of people that don't want things done
to their neck with chiropractors. I don't think that that's unique.
And also Hassan works out a lot. He could have had like like
back damage because he does a lot of working out.
Like that's very very very possible. It's extremely possible.
>> It's compensated too much. It's very reasonable that
somebody wouldn't want a chiropractor to crack your neck. >> I
didn't even know that. >> It's extremely reasonable.
>> Why am Why do I have to defend this? This is
[__] [__] man. Why y'all DO
WHY DO Y'ALL do this? Like this is this is so dumb.
>> Chinese government to say no. Okay, so this guy letting
him anywhere near your go hang out with Republicans. Go to the
dangerous places and get shot. Okay, all of us will clap for
you. I promise. All right, go to the Republican places. Go to
the edgy places. Go >> Jesus. Why do you say this?
>> We did react to this yesterday. There's more stuff.
So, we're checking out some >> What are you doing? >> More
responses going on. Why would you say this is insane streamer
drama? Asthma most affected. It is. No, it is. Every single time
there's streamer drama, it's all about how I react to it. It's
like there's some drama with techone or the drama with the call.
This fat losser is balding. Asmin Gold just sitting there like
[laughter] if he's if he's balding, I'm cooked, dude.
>> praying piece of to show up at a liberal protest for
6 hours. You can come and finger wave, go hang out with tankies
or whatever, but stay the away from liberal protest. This fat
losser, this balding, graying piece of [__] to show
up at a liberal protest for 6 hours. You can come and finger
wave and virtually signal to everybody else that you do, that
you matter. You don't matter. Nobody likes you. I literally I
didn't want to reveal this, but the reason why I've been off
stream so much is I actually gained with my close personal friend.
Uh, I'll just say his last name is Mdani. And he says that him
dipped. Booten dipped.
>> All right.
>> And his wife talk about Hassan all the time, 24/7. All
we do is we queue up Arc writers and we run around the lobby.
We just talk about his son constantly. They say they hate him,
that he's a loser, that his hair is falling out, that he needs
to up his TRT, he's small. His >> Bro, he's blocking off
the camera because he's like, "No, no, no, no, no. You're not
dragging me down at this ship. You're going down there. I'm getting
on a life raft, bro. Like, uh-uh. Nope. No, no, no. I'm roaching
>> Suck. His dog isn't in the background anymore. He just
everything about him is horrible. He's a loser. Okay, so yeah.
>> What a show.
I don't even know what to say, guys. This is the ultimate crash
out. I think that it's so dangerous to be ad >> um I don't
think anyone clipped that Hassan revealed he tal I mean people
knew Hassan talking for people to intercept and interfere with
people in their personal life and in real life I think it's so
dangerous I think it's completely uncalled for
>> yeah that's that's essentially Destiny's position from
back here in 2023 right where is this from 2023 that's Destiny's
position back here
he used to think this like quite literally he used to think this
this was his position as well as gold really dangerous to ask
people to go meet up with someone in real life to provide their
location say go [__] with this guy go interfere with
them yep 100%
so easy to get Destiny quote tweets this this guy is literally
supporting the current admin assassinating Americans in the street
and says my comments are too far do streamers think the news
is just some entertainment for them to cover completely divorced
from reality
no I justand
didn't do that though.
Does Destiny forget who he was saying should get killed? Is he
just going to say Asmin Gold should get killed now? Or like he
might be able to use this excuse if
Asmin go if he was advocating for Asmin Gold to die. He could
say, "Oh, well, you know, Asmin Gold wants people
but Hassan didn't do that.
That's very weird. I don't get it."
Okay. Anyway, it's obviously a bad idea to advocate for people
to track down and engage in hostile confrontation with a streamer
in real life. Destiny literally agrees with this. It's not even
a little bit confusing. It's not even a little
Destiny responds, "This was yesterday as well." Yeah, this is
yesterday as well. So, telling people they're not welcome in
your political movement equals hostile confrontation. Yes, you
said bully.
You literally said bully. Go bully this guy. Go bully this guy.
Go bully this guy. That is by definition a hostile confrontation.
What the is this weird semantic game you're attempting here?
Uh, are you saying bullying is hostile? Um,
I think you need to I think you need to figure out your definitions,
buddy. Bullying is hostile. Kids engage in bullying. Grow up,
Asmin Gold. I can already It's already there. God, why am I even
covering this? Holy mate, you literally advocate for capital
punishment for every political figure and illegal immigrant
and illegal immigrant and other nations population that you don't
like. You have zero room to talk here unless Okay, I don't care.
This is what This is what aboutism.
Is this the same what aboutism again? Uh, Asold, did you know
that you're actually bad and you can't complain about me cuz
you're bad? Do you know that? It's obviously a bad idea to advocate
to track people down. Engage in hostile confrontation with streamer
in real life. Wait, did he just respond with the same thing?
Dude, the roach tech is amazing. He just responded with the exact
same thing. He just responded. He responded the exact same way.
You love to see it. He just responded with the same thing again.
It's obviously a bad idea. Hey, how about you respond to what
I said? It's obviously a bad idea to track down and engage in
a hostile confrontation with a streamer in real life. Damn.
Damn.
Okay. All right. We get a new response to this one. Destiny never
did that, though. He's proposing it and then he doubled down
on saying it should be done. This guy's a This guy is an actual
Let's immediately filter this guy out. That person doesn't need
to be talked about, engaged with it, or anything. That person's
a complete [__] Perfect.
Uh, hold on. Let's take a look at this
We don't have anything from Destiny. Unlucky.
Unlucky.
It's what Destiny does. Repeats the same thing over and over
again until the person responds. That he does. So, I thought
there was responses to this today. Are there not responses for
this like today? Hold on. Let me see here. There's like some
rally stuff which is responding to this as defense. >> This
is what Destiny does, mate. You This is >> Oh, here. Hold
on. Let's see. >> This is what Destiny does, mate. You
This is some other bull. It has nothing to do with this. It has
nothing to do with this. This has nothing to do with what I said.
You're bringing in something totally irrelevant so you can make
an argument for something that you said that was stupid. Yes,
you are a idiot for going out there and telling anybody that
they should be bullying.
dude, the roach counter is perfect here.
Like, it's got to be bad when you're just getting totally intellectually
dominated by Asmin Gold. Hey, you're like pointing something
totally irrelevant out. You want to just engage with what I said?
>> Harassing a person in real life, triangulating their
location from a live stream, and then sniping them in it. You
were a [__] You're advocating for potential violence
and you are asking for trouble.
Now,
I do believe that Asmin Gold has done similar things.
I do think he has. I think his stuff over the Charlie Kirk was
insane trying to track down people's jobs and get them fired.
I don't know if he tracked down anything beyond their like full
do sorry their their name docs and jobs but from somebody's name
and their job which ostensibly can give state a lot of times
I do think that you could easily track them down if you wanted
to
he's drawing attention in a negative way asking them for them
to be interfered with I do think there are some comp comparable
things there but that doesn't make Destiny okay that makes both
of them
right it doesn't make one of them good it doesn't make both of
them
It makes them both totally deranged.
Obviously, nobody should be advocating for this. Even if you
disagree with Assan, even if you think Assan is a piece of nobody
should be going around and saying this and these weird rationalizations
about how, oh well, actually, because you said this other thing,
it's okay for me to be. No, that's not how it works. It's not.
I'm sorry. This is it. It's constantly every single time. But
what about this other thing? This is Reddit tier false equivalency
logic. This doesn't work. It's just stupid.
Everything about this is stupid,
dude. Asminold.
What if what if being covered in filth 24/7 was the only thing
keeping this guy down? What if he's like ascending slowly? Every
every day he compounds another day on the shower streak. He just
becomes more intelligent. We might be in trouble, guys. Okay,
we might be in trouble. This guy's gonna take Oh, this guy's
going to take um
Oh, mold bug. Curtis Jarvin. He's going to take Curtis Jarvin's
place as the right-wing think tank guy. Okay. The right-wing
thought leader. Every if he can shower 60 days in a row, he will
ascend past Curtis Jarvin. Okay.
>> It's 5-year-old logic. Yeah. No, you you can't go out
and harass people in real life. Like anybody advocating for that
is wrong.
Duh.
How many like how many more people need to get? I mean, do you
understand? Like streamers deal with like this all the time when
you have somebody like Destiny that's going out there and promoting
that [__] That's crazy.
Nobody should be promoting this.
And by the way, it's like obviously true. It's like trivially
true that he's saying you should try to figure out where Hersan
is and harass him, right? He's like, it's trivially obvious that
that's what he's advocating for when he says, "Oh, Dan should
make an app to do that thing." And then he doubles down on it,
right? It's not even we can't even really get away from this
at all. Now, I think there's a response to this.
Oh, is it the Really response?
It is the Really response. Okay, hold on. The substance is fighting
with Really. Uh-oh.
Let's see. I don't go get how this is wrong. as long as he isn't
advocating for violence. Why can't someone say that paid political
opposition posing as someone on the left should be bullied out
of our public events?
Uh because I think you do it in a way that wasn't just like,
let's just be honest, if that's where you were approaching it
from, you would have come up with a way to not ambiguously advocate
for violence in a way that you have said is advocating for harm
in the past. If you had just thought, "Oh, we need to make sure
Hassan is not at our events." By the way, I don't know why you'd
say that the Minnesota events are more like there are probably
a lot of people who are all over the left-wing political spectrum
at those events. I don't know why you'd say they're just liberal
events. That seems needlessly reductionist like totally. But
it's fine if you want to say that. Okay.
Why Destiny, if he just thought, oh, Hassan shouldn't be at these
protests, he would have thought of way to say it of a way to
say it that didn't also include this element of harm, this thing
he thinks is harmful himself,
right?
Like let's just ponder for a second. I think Assan shouldn't
be at these protests. I don't think Assan should be allowed at
these protests. I think you shouldn't engage with Assan. If you
happen to see him, you should never go find him. But if you happen
to see him, just be like
Kaya or some
never go find him. I I'd never advocate for finding him. He would
have said some like this, right? But he didn't. He was just he
was just angry, mad, seething in the morning. It's the same thing
where he comes out and calls Ethan a, right? I think there's
the same kind of morning post where he was doing this before
his stream. He like wakes up, he gets super mad about Twitter
and then he like calls Ethan who his children. That's a Destiny
quote. Ethan Klein is a who his children. Destiny who virtue
signaled to Pisco about how bad it was that that he was supporting
anyone or even questioning that Denim's got CPS called on Ethan
Klein went to his chat and said, "Yeah, Ethan Klein, Steven Benell
the third, second, I forget. second I think went to his chat
and said Ethan Klein is a who his children
as if that's not far worse than what Denims was
Okay, so there's that.
All right, there's that. Now we need to go back to this tweet
and I just right here. Okay, I don't get this wrong as long as
he isn't advocating for violence. Why can't someone say that?
That play paid political opposition, by the way, not proven.
Not proven at all. Now, I agree that he did a propaganda tour,
but the idea that he's paid is totally made up, right? That's
invented.
So, if you want to be honest about it, you could be cuz I I have
a feeling the next the next thing in the dialogue tree from there
would be, "Well, didn't Hassan say that we're paid by Israel
without Yes, that was bad. You shouldn't do that." Yeah, lying
is bad. I'm going to go with the ultra based position of lying
is bad.
Okay. As long as he isn't advocating for violence, why can't
someone say that paid political opposition posing as someone
on the left should be bullied out of our public events? Um,
I would say again bullied out of the events is ambiguous. You're
drawing negative like you're drawing negative uh what's the word?
Attention to them. You're drawing negative attention to them
and saying people should be stalking them. Like it is good is
morally good to stalk them.
We all can identify that that's bad. We could identify that it
was bad, right? And sorry, bullied. Like you're asking for something
negative, a negative public interaction with them as well, which
is essentially 99.9%
of what's going on here, right?
Where Destiny freaked the out and doxed this person. So I Yeah,
the live tracking part actually that is true watching you back.
It's different from saying, "Oh, Hassan's here. You should go
get him." It's saying you should track him. You should figure
out where he is. You should always be following him. So whenever
somebody wants they can figure out where he is and do something.
Yeah. Yeah. It's obviously bad.
And the M and Bailey about paid political actors even enga engaging
with that at all is totally
um and I I will call out just Pisco and Josiah because they did
this in the conservative thing where they were like actually
it's a point about Trump. No, it wasn't. It was him being emotionally
disregulated, losing his temper and talking about how he wants
conservatives to be scared for their lives. He admitted as much
on Piers Morgan because he's a
I don't want to add anything else because I'm on Twitch because
he is a Okay, so he admitted as much. He broke on it on Piers
Morgan. Literally, he has agreed with Andrew Wilson that he was
calling for violence against conservatives. He was saying conservatives
should be scared. He was saying he was reveling in the fact that
conservatives might be scared.
It wasn't a point about what you're saying. It wasn't the Bailey.
It wasn't the thing he said after to justify being
first thing. The second point people could agree with. It's just
it's fine. The second point I don't Yeah, you should focus on
Trump. You should say Trump should disavow the violence anyway.
Why stop at the live tracking? Just tell people to go to his
house. I guess
I mean I I Destiny has to understand that if Hassan wanted to
go publish like about him, that would be totally fair game. Hassan
won't do that cuz he's not going to invite that. But like you
based on this clip right here,
that's that's the same thing, right? The Docs in response. No,
Destiny. Luckily, I don't think he could be much more doxed.
So, you know, luckily in that case, he's kind of immune. You
can't hurt me on that one anymore.
Anyway, okay,
let's look at the response to to substance here.
Can't be serious when this same guy said
Uh, does anyone have a link to the video? I think I honestly
think you could perfectly justify attacking such RL for statements
like this.
uh didn't look into the context of this. This is actually a totally
insane thing to say based on that clip. I remember what the clip
is. This is the El Klein one. Are you really just cool with calls
for IRL harassment now? That would have been unheard of in this
space a few years ago. Yes, supporting a fascist state by co-opting
leftwing spaces should get you bullied.
So, he's supporting Trump by co-opting leftwing spaces.
Ah, man.
Really fell down the hutch.
Ah, this will
I don't like this. I need to think a little bit more. I I want
to kind of figure out how to argue this. I'd like to argue with
Hutch about it, but I I do want to figure out how to argue this
because this seems like the worst possible point
in my opinion.
Call Really? I'm not arguing about it off the cuff.
I have no interest. I have no interest. Uh, no, you don't. You
guys shouldn't hate all relevant. This is probably his opinion.
I think he's wrong. You guys shouldn't hate All Relevant. Some
people are like, "Oh, you should hate." No. Shut the [__]
up. By the way, Rei could have easily gone back to Destiny Sphere,
just like I has, just like um Hutch has. He could have easily
done that. He could have easily said, "Oh, this J guy, I don't
want anything to do with him." He doesn't do that cuz he actually
has a spine. He's actually a good person. And anybody who's going
to try to sh on him can suck my dick. Okay, get the [__]
out of my chat.
I I'm sorry. You're just wrong. He's a good person fundamentally.
I don't agree with the argument, but I'm happy that somebody
is here who can represent the other side of the argument so I
can actually argue with them cuz guess what? Everybody else who
believes what he believes actually just blocks me and refuses
to engage whatsoever.
So, how about we don't be to the few people who will actually
engage.
Thank you. I don't mind if you disagree
Obviously, you can disagree with them.
Uh I don't remember what the clip was. Oh, right. There's no
more here. This was the Elila Klein
raider of Ramala.
Yeah, she would have been a valid military target back in the
day when she was on the raid into It wasn't Raala though, right?
Was it Ramala where she went? I forget where it was. I think
it was not Ramala. I think it was a different city. Anyway, yeah,
I don't I don't think it's smart to say that you support this.
I especially don't think it's smart to say without listening
to the
to the full clip, right? Cuz so this is he's just getting caught
by the Mton Bailey here. I think that's what's happening is he's
just getting caught by the Mutton Bailey, right? You listen to
what Destiny says in the Asen Gold clip he wants versus actually
reading the logs about what he said and doubling down on those
logs, right? You could see that I think in this
Oh, no. It's this one. >> This is what Destiny's bringing
in. >> Yeah. Yeah. So, like
I think Rey's missing the initial context. I think with the initial
context, you'd probably actually just have the correct opinion.
I think. Anyway, cool. Well, that's that story. Apparently another
Asthold response to something Destiny said today.
We'll see. Destiny loses it. Responding to Asminold. I wish his
mom Oh, so Destiny just didn't respond again. Did Destiny just
fail to address Asmin Gold's point again and he just gets to
say the same thing? No way. There's no way that Asminold is the
person who intellectually breaks
That's got to, bro. That's got to discredit everything you've
done in your entire life online. You get emotionally broken and
intellectually broken by
>> I understand. You're such a Holy
I wish his mom had a bigger oxygen tank so this wouldn't be with
us anymore. Jesus Christ. What a stupid comment to make. >> You're
getting mad because you know I'm >> You're trying to make
an emotionally compromising comment to me because you know that
I'm right. That's what it is. See, now he's getting upset. That's
it. This is crazy. What is wrong with you?
Classic debate tactic, by the way, trying to throw a personal
insult to get the person off balance. It's just exactly what
he's done.
>> I mean, he does this all the time. He did it with his
son two days ago. How does someone make emotional grandson arguments
with saying such emotionally charged insults? He literally destroys
his own argument in the same sentence. I mean, who cares, right?
As she died in explosion, it's a meme or a dumb take ad. No,
she died of cancer. No, she had COPD. She had instage COPD and
the fire from the oxygen tank sent her to the hospital that day,
but she was going to go anyway. Like the the fire from the oxygen
tank actually had nothing to do with her dying. It really didn't.
Uh this was just something that people invented on social media
because it's like a good it's like a good imagery, right? Uh
that's the reason why. And so anyway, Jesus associ
right. Let's listen to Destiny for a mental for political takes
too. like, "Oh yeah, if I disagree with you, that means I can
advocate for somebody to kill you if I can falsely equate what
you're saying to something that I think." It's such a ridiculous,
stupid thing to say. And I I honestly like I mean, you're you're
borderline advocating for
Dude, [clears throat] he actually got it right there. I thought
he was going to say Destiny was advocating for like killing someone,
but that's not quite he was saying what he's doing is saying
this is bad enough that you could justify Hassan, but he is not
understanding the context of the full clip, the full context
of the clip. So, he misunderstands it and says you could justify
it, which by the way is sort of advocating for it, but there's
like a little hook there where Destiny would do the M and Bailey
again. YOU GO, "OH, YOU GOT IT TOTALLY WRONG." BUT Asmin Gold,
you know,
bro, this guy, since this guy started
he's like he's like a 90-day shower streak away from being a
liberal. I can >> advocate for somebody to kill you. If
I can falsely equate what you're saying to something that I think
>> Yeah. If he can if he can if I can falsely equate something
you're saying to something I think, like what I think it is,
if I can basically if I can twist what you're saying into like
something where I would Yeah. You should you you would die. If
you're if you're saying Hila Klein could die, well then you could
die. >> It's such a ridiculous stupid thing to say. And
I I honestly like I mean you're you're borderline advocating
for like basically people. I mean what are you doing? You're
right. Destiny shouldn't have been for what he does, but he should
give Twitch reasons to keep the promo. I mean this is insane
to say that. It really is. It's nuts. So uh talking about your
parent I mean again Destiny has enough of his own real life problems.
I don't want to get into that. I don't really care about that
if you want me to be honest. Somebody insults my parents. They
insult my family. Like, what am I supposed to say? Am I gonna
make a joke about Destiny? Like, I I don't care what Destiny's
personal life is. It literally is of such little consequence
to me that I haven't even read about it. I don't care what he
says about my mom or my parents. I care about what he's saying
about this political stuff. And the fact that he's out there
advocating and trying to make a false equivalency to uh going
out there and saying that somebody should be tried for treason
versus it's okay to politically people that you don't like. To
think that that's the same thing is a Reddit tier false equivalency.
And Destiny does this constantly. And you see this all the time,
right? Like whenever Destiny said something, like I want you
to keep in mind when Destiny said what he was just saying, I
actually responded to what his points were. He doesn't respond
to what my points are. He's not explaining to what I'm saying
is wrong. No, he's not doing any of that. What he is doing is
he's just making personal insults and he's saying an equivalent
thing to that in his mind. Uh, that's the opposite. That's it.
People never actually respond to what I'm saying.
Uh, well, he didn't respond to what Asengo was saying that I
saw at least.
Ah, hold on.
Didn't see it if he did. So, basically just like, do you really
think it's appropriate now? Now, after two days, okay, Destiny
had time to think about it. He's getting ready to perfectly project
his his Bailey now. Okay, he's worked on it. He said something
totally ridiculous. He hadn't pre-thought it out, right? Hadn't
thought it out at all. Not even a little bit. Right now, he's
going to pretend that he wasn't just like angry at Hassan one
morning and getting mad and saying, "We should track this guy.
I know this was with this guy. We should just track this guy
everywhere." Going to pretend that he was making a political
point, right? The clip is not the first instance. The first instance
is him in the chat complaining about it. Right?
So, if we look at the chat logs, which is the Viva whatever tweet
again. Okay, let me pull this up. We look at the chat logs. This
is where he first says it. This is the emotional outburst. This
is him losing his
Let me find it. Let me find it. Let me find it. This one right
>> Okay. If Dan wants to do something useful and still
be a Hassan hater, he should create a track Hassan
X account that posts his current location when he's at a protest.
His location should be publicly available at all times while
he's live streaming.
Right? This is the initial emotional
I don't want I don't give a what your arguments are after the
fact after you get called out for this after people get mad at
you. I don't care what you can say. Well, this is what actually
what I really meant was something totally different. Nobody cares.
Shut up.
>> this is apparently this is now by the way. First it
was no, we just want to bully him. First he was saying no, no,
no, you shouldn't be advocating for violence, right? We're not
advocating for violence. First he was saying we're just bullying
him. So I don't know why we might be going somewhere where it's
advocating for political violence. Maybe he's just responding
to Asmin Gold now >> The commentators. >> Okay. Asmin
Gold, Hassan, Destiny,
>> And then this here is like
politics. politics. Yes, I see that. >> And it's like this
is like it's a fake world. Nothing is real. We can say whatever,
do whatever, blah blah blah. But as soon as Destiny's like, hm,
you know, somebody could this guy up for saying this. Now these
guys lose their mind over it. >> Yeah, you can do politics
without advocating for being violent against people that are
that have opinions. Yeah, obviously. Like is what the what are
you talking about? Are you >> like this is not a fake world?
This is not like just pretend. I I don't like how streamers engage
with
>> um I don't think basically I think Asmin Gold's saying
that he's never advocated for somebody to die
without a trial in a way that like hey just I want a random vigilante
to kill this guy. That's what he's trying to say right when he
says people should be hung. He's saying no I want a political
process to go through and convict these
One second. Sorry I just grabbed some food and I'm chewing and
talking. Not great.
So he that's what Asagold is trying to say is I want a political
process and Destiny's going to say well actually your the way
you talk and the way you like normalize this administration gets
people therefore I think you're responsible for their deaths.
He's going to do the denims thing right.
I personally think as can be very harmful. I think he is harmful
but you don't get to fight his ideas. You don't get to fight
the harmful things he says with violence. That's not the world
we live in. That's not the world we all opted for. You want to
live in that world. There's like a whole bunch of countries who
do believe in like might makes right where you could just go
kill people you disagree with that you think are harmful that
their speech is harmful right as gold docs people are saying
I think that's crazy yes that doesn't make either of their ideas
correct that doesn't matter in terms of analyzing Destiny's statement
it doesn't matter asold could be openly doxing a ton of people
and he would still be correct when he's pointing out Destiny's
failings right
you understand even less
you understand right we we all understand that that there's in
a vacuum. [clears throat]
Now, I I've I've already said I do think as really harmful. I
do think he's really [__] up, but you don't get to
say that, oh, we should kill this guy. Was Asmin doxed? I believe
Asmin posted names, profiles, and jobs of people who celebrated
the death of Charlie Kirk. He like facilitated a website being
made or just helped market the website that posted these docs
and try to get these people fired.
So, obviously, you're putting their public information out there,
putting a target on them. Um, I I think he would even agree that
that's probably sketchy. Maybe not quite as bad as posting somebody's
live updated location, right?
But it is still bad in the same vein. >> Politics is just
a pretend world. >> What do you mean it's a pretend world?
So, because it's not a pretend world, you can advocate for people
to get What is wrong with you? >> Like, I have a feeling
that if I were to say, I think somebody should like execute Asmin
Gold, I think he would lose his I think he would get mad at >> No
way. No way. This is Oh my god, this guy is so Redditrained.
It's actually embarrassing. It is genuinely embarrassing. He
thinks that Asigold doesn't know how Destiny sets up arguments.
Destiny's got a whole thing where he's setting this up basically
to get Asminold to do this for a clip, right? That's what he's
trying to do. As Destiny's going to go and like know that Asminold
will pause and go like, "This guy's dumb. This guy's dumb." He
hasn't even made his point yet. He's like walking slowly towards
this point hoping people will get. >> There's some kind
of inconsistency.
This is insane. You're talking about advocating for somebody.
>> Oh my god. This is like saying that because you advocate
by the way he just openly advocates for members of the Republican
party to get kicked on Twitter,
right? Like I if I'm not mistaken, somebody sent me like a bunch
of Did he not put like imagine how much somebody will get paid
if they do it and then he just responded with that to like a
whole bunch of rep like he was just openly advocating for those
people to be killed as well. >> For self-defense that means
it's okay for me to you.
>> Just because it's the same base action doesn't mean
that it's the same thing.
This is like here, let me remove all context, all nuance and
all logic out of this and then instead of that bake this false
equivalency that justifies me advocating for vigilante violence.
>> This is
JD V does not push for treason with capital punishment against
Tim
>> Do not vote for him. Mhm.
If Trump does not deliver that, do not vote for him the third
time. >> Like, you're saying that this guy should
>> So, hold on.
Wasn't there a defense of Biden? I would love to know Desi's
thoughts on that. Didn't Biden say something about trying to
like try somebody? Who did it? Maybe I'm misreme remembering.
Yeah, maybe I'm misremembering. Maybe somebody else said Biden
should be tried. There was like a big controversy around this
in politics just a while back of saying like somebody should
be tried. I thought it was Biden in some state of the union speech
or some maybe it was when he got into office. I can't remember
talking about how some people should be tried like and I think
implied executed.
So I'd love to see what the comments were there because that
would be a similar situation where he did imply that it should
be a trial. That should lead to something, right?
It might have been a Republican saying Biden should be tried
and executed to be honest with you. Wasn't that MTG to Biden?
It might have been MTG to Biden. Yeah, I'm trying to think of
how that was. So, I just want to know how people reacted to that
situation to see if it's just bias affecting them here. Now,
you can No, I'm saying you should be on trial for it. That's
the difference is that whenever you're advocating for vigilante
justice and vigilante violence, there is no trial. There is no
accountability.
Oh, I guess you could just go to all of the Vosch stochcastic
terrorism stuff, right?
Isn't that all of the Vosch stocastic terrorism stuff right there?
Oh, it was Charlie Kirk about Biden, right? Jay Chris,
it was Charlie Kirk about Biden. It was in the Charlie Kirk like
best greatest hits of unhinged things he
Yeah, you just go to the Vos stochastic terrorisms terrorism
arguments and yeah, just go pull from those. there are no protective
measures and it is completely up to whatever crazy person out
there to act on whatever impulse they have and do it. Whenever
I advocate for that, this is the this is the issue, right? Is
that this is like saying, well, how can you be against violence
if you think the police should apprehend criminals? Yes, obviously
there should be some degree of accountability to somebody that's
doing something illegal or breaking the law or siding with a
foreign country. This is like Luigi. Yeah, exactly. Like Luigi
is totally different than the state executing somebody for doing
something wrong. Like this I it is unbelievable how every single
one of Destiny's arguments to justify his unhinged stupid rhetoric
about oh wow remember like it's it's literally just that [clears throat]
and this is what they try to do right this is why it's really
useful to have the cultlike community.
So instead of questioning you they'll just boost the Bailey.
they will boost the Bailey instead of the Mott. So, we don't
even see the logs anymore. There's a whole bunch of tweets. You
don't even see the original logs anymore, right? Of what he originally
said.
You just see the the Bailey only. And then people forget that
the reason everybody was mad was because of what he was advocating
for in the first place. Like whenever he said that the kids in
the the Texas flood, he was saying like I don't know if he said
they deserved it or he was making jokes about it and then he
was saying bad stuff about the guy that got killed at the Texas
Trump or >> Oh, he doesn't even know that story. Um Destiny
was joking about how those kids jumped off, those like 10 and
12y old girls rally watching off, right? And then I think like
two days later asked a daughter or asked a father if his daughter
smashed his like 12-year-old daughter going on her first date
or something. Guy really loves kids for some reason. I don't
know why. This is very weird how he um
kids a lot all the time. >> This is just a very very common
parallel that Destiny does is that he listens to the dumbest
person on the internet and he says wait a minute I can do you.
Oh. Uh, Mott and Bailey is like you basically give a bad argument
or you say something wrong or you I think you give like a bait
argument because you So it's like a it's like a trap. The mod
is like the trap and then you lead them to the Bailey. You know,
I I've I've just heard it used. I don't actually think I know
the definition. I know how to say it. It's like you basically
give one argument and then you represent the second argument,
the more concrete argument because you've baited somebody into
arguing with you, right?
uh Montton Bailey fallacy,
but I actually don't know like the strict what I could say here.
It's a form of argument and an informal fall fallacy where an
arguer conflates two positions that share similarities. One modest
and easy to defend, the M, and one much harder or oh, sorry,
the Bailey is the one that's much harder and uh controversial.
Arguer advances the controversial position, but when challenged,
insists the the that only the more modest position is being advanced.
Yes, M. And Bailey, I actually got that totally wrong. I flipped
them,
but I I was basically going for this, right? You basically have
one position, one easily defensible position, and then all they
do is amplify the easily defensible position, and everybody looks
like they got mad for the easily defensible position without
actually tracking where it came from.
And I'm just surprised that anybody
falls for that anymore because it's usually it's just so easy
to understand, right? Like when Destiny says when he he when
he posts like somebody would get paid a lot if they Steven Miller
when he says that on Twitter like Steen Miller and you make a
bunch of money when he says that he's probably going to say oh
I just think we should hold government accountable for the violence
that's being done on the citizens right and then all you'll ever
see if you're like somebody on a or something all you'll ever
see is wait people are mad at Destiny cuz he's saying the government
should be held accountable. Why would you get mad at Destiny
for saying that the government should be held accountable? It's
like well no that's actually not why anybody got mad in the first
place. Yeah, it's the whole It's literally the whole career,
right? It's uh very goofy. Very, very goofy. Anyway,
>> That's what he does every single time. This is so
And again, this is a Reddit tier false equivalency so he can
justify advocating for violence and being an idiot.
The The funny thing is it's not even advocating for violence
because I don't think he actually genuinely advocates for violence.
I think he just gets really emotionally dregulated. He gets really
upset. I don't know what he looks at on his phone in the morning.
Just gets very angry and throws a temper tantrum. And usually
that's done via Twitter or his chat or whatever, right? It's
why he woke up and called Ethan Klein a who his children. It's
why he woke up and said Hassan should be tracked. It's why he
woke up one morning and posted a bunch of doc bins in his Discord
or sorry in his DG chat, right? Like the the docses of a bunch
of people. It's like why he wakes up in the morning, he's really
mad, he's cranky, and then he decides he's just gonna be a piece
of [__] And then he tries to
he tries to say, "Oh, I was making this point." No, you weren't
making that point. You were just have no impulse control. You
are just like a low impulse control,
tantrum throwing baby. That's all it is. And you might be okay
at making arguments after that, but that part's the problem.
That's what we're talking about. >> That's it. This is
like saying again, because you support self-defense, that means
I should be able to shoot you. No, absolutely not. Just because
you say, "Okay, in some circumstances
this would be acceptable, that doesn't mean that automatically
in every circumstance it's always acceptable." All right.
I don't know if Desty's responded to this yet. Wait, I did get
given a Reddit thing. Maybe. Um,
no, I think this is the last clip. I think this is the last response.
If there's another response in this, we could cover it. Otherwise,
guys, I'm going to kick for the rest of the